I
hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar control experiments
for reproducible microbiome research I
am Brenda Kelly Kim of lab roots and
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab groups the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's also brought to you by lab roots to
learn more please visit www a Bruce com
let's get started you can post questions
to the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the Q&A box
which will open when you click the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience any technical problems seeing
or hearing this presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button lower left I'd like to
now present today's speaker dr. Paul
Brooks dr. Brooks is the statistics and
analysis team leader for the NIH funded
multi almec microbiome study pregnancy
initiatives mom's p I at vmc vcu.edu and
is a fellow at the Center for the Study
of biological complexity at Virginia
Commonwealth University he recently
returned to VCU after serving as a
visiting research fellow at the
statistical and applied mathematical
sciences institute where he led working
groups and developing methods for
analyzing microbiome data as part of the
beyond bioinformatics program he
received a PhD and micro bio data as
part of operations research from Georgia
Tech and in his research has used
optimization to design new data analysis
methods and has applied them to
biomedical data recently he has worked
to bring perspectives
from industrial statistics to bear on
interpretation of life sciences data dr.
Brooks will now be in his presentation
thanks Brenda thanks for that
introduction thanks to the organizers
for inviting me in particular to fill
guys so I am as Brenda mentioned on the
statistics and analysis team leader for
our work here at VCU with the human
microbiome project and I've been working
with microbiome data for several years
but i'm not a microbiologist so what I'd
like to do is talk to you about ways you
can leverage people like me to
understand better the measurement
protocols that we use for microbiome
research I'm going to be building on
perhaps on some of the previous
presentations such as by Curtis Hutton
halloran Jack Gilbert and so I'd
encourage you to if you didn't get a
chance to go back and visit those when
they come when they come online and are
available so my goal today is to kind of
highlight unanswered questions that we
have in the way that we measure the
microbiome I'm going to focus on the 16s
sequencing surveys protocols because we
we feel like we know them best but yet I
feel like we have still quite a few
unanswered questions in regard to
microbiome research there are a number
of other omics measurements technologies
coming online and and I feel like a lot
of the challenges that we still have
with 16 s measurements will translate to
these new protocols as well including
cytokine measurements other sequencing
technologies including whole genome
sequencing meta transcriptomics and and
then mass spectroscopy based measurement
such as metal omics
16s rrna surveys samples are collected
they undergo the filtered undergo DNA
extraction DNA extracted from the
bacteria pcr the 16s gene is simplified
in a PCR reaction and then the DNA
fragments are sequenced and then the DNA
fragments undergo bioinformatics
processing to assign from taxonomic
classification and so what I want to
talk about is about how what we observe
at the end of the pipeline relates to
what is actually in the original
environment what what transformation
does the signal go through to what we
observe compared to what's in the
original environment so I want to kind
of overall go to dispel two myths here
the first is that all labs should use
the same protocols for the microbiome
measurement what what I've seen over the
years and in viewing separate separate
microbiome projects is that different
labs will engineer their protocols for
their particular environment of interest
there are depending on the biological
questions that are asked they need to
make sure that they detect certain
bacteria or amplify certain parts of
their environment to understand what's
going on and so therefore labs we use
different protocols and we need to know
understand the effects of these choices
of protocols so that we can
appropriately represent our results the
second myth is at any problems that we
have in terms of reflecting reality with
our with our data the myth is that well
we we just have to wait until technology
advances further that that sequencing
technology has to advance before we can
before we can trust the measurements
that we have
and I'd like to refute that and propose
ways that a lot of these challenges can
be overcome with control experiments and
experiments with environmental samples
and statistical modeling so I have the
outline for my clock I'm going to cover
for four basic areas here and for each
what I'm going to do is is to give a
what I call the common view and it's
neither I call it a view it's neither
been proved true or false in my opinion
though I think there are some some some
who think that these questions are
settled so i'll give the common view
significant to the question remaining
unanswered questions and some or at
least incompletely answered some initial
findings and then suggestions on how to
get answers so the four areas are
include detecting rare taxa and how that
relates to sequencing depth and in
library size the second will be
compatible decide on what's the best
analysis method for making and
confirming scientific discoveries
regarding microbiome data and then the
third relates to recovering true
biological signals above noise and that
that has to do with measuring text and
understanding understanding technical
variation and addressing it properly and
then the fourth is is really the the
main event for me because that's where
i'll present mostly much of the work
that that we've done in our lab in terms
of overcoming bias so this is using
experiments and modeling to be able to
counteract the these transformations
that undergo our signals so in order to
predict true community composition based
on what we observe okay so the four
common view again has to do with rare
taxa so the idea is that samples with
fewer reads detector array attacker and
the significance of this is that our
test statistic will test that we use the
power of them may depend on library
sighs and this ability to detect rare
taxa here I've got stacks stacked area
plots of the throat and tongue dorsum in
there two different body sites the
bacteria the samples are along the
x-axis and the amount of each bacterium
observed is on the y-axis and across the
populations it doesn't appear to be too
much of a difference we do have methods
that do that discriminate them if we
don't the common view is if we don't
account for library size we make it we
may get false positives and in terms of
differences between between environments
or asking for a particular bacterium
this bacterium present in different
quantities in one environment versus the
other for the question here with rare
taxes is zero really zero when we see
when we don't see a taxon really not
there or or are we just not picking it
up and so the the unanswered questions
here are is this really an issue with
sequencing depth or is it a matter of
primer mismatch or both so often i
believe microbiologist and statisticians
view microbiome experiments as drawing
balls out of urns kind of experiments
when really what we're doing is we are
we are fishing for it be the arms would
not filled with balls that are inanimate
they're filled with fish if you will
bacteria and they have different
appetite for our bait which are the
primers and so we're going to catch
oarfish if they like if they match our
bait better in terms of the primer
matches to carry the analogy so so
really i think these questions are our
remain to be answered does sequencing
depth of affect our ability to detect
rare taxa how can we evaluate our
ability to detect or attack so are they
rare because of their abundance their
low abundance the primary mismatch or
both and when is attacks aren't really
present or absent and implicit in here
is the idea that abundance in the
community what we mean is is that there
is a low biomass for this particular
organism and it could be effects based
on low biomass for the for the for the
sample as well so this is an example as
Brenda mentioned are our projects are
focused on maternal health and so we
look at the vaginal microbiome and it
was important to us to engineer our
protocols to be able to detect chlamydia
in our samples and so each we started
with a traditional the original p1
jumpstart primers and they are unable to
detect chlamydia and this is what you're
seeing here is two stacked bar plots for
two different Mach communities where we
knew it was in there and we spiked in
for each for each mark community we
spiked in on a certain amount of
chlamydia and then and then try to
recover them based on different choices
of primers so the the original jumpstart
primers they in this chlamydia
completely so we ended up having to work
to design our own primers to target that
and you can see with these other primers
there's different efficiencies and in
recovering in recovering chlamydia so in
this case it was not so much the amount
of committee because it's the same for
all these samples but rather the the
primer mismatch that that
makes chlamydia a rare taxa or appear to
be a rare taxa so this is evidence that
the the choice of a primer doesn't
matter now whether that's the only thing
or if low biomass also might matter what
I say that that's unanswered still this
is these are results from positive
controls so this is a mock community
that we ran with each each run of our
experiments well we have ended up with
172 replicates of the same sample this
is a mock community so we knew it was in
there and what I'm plotting here is the
number of unexpected counts unexpected
DNA fragments as a function of the
library size for the total number of
fragments and what you can see is that
we do get for our for these same samples
we get a variety of library sizes across
the x-axis but that the unexpected
counts the contamination the
contaminated accounts do not appear to
increase with with library size so this
would seem to indicate that if we're
going to determine if something is
present or absent in a sample we should
use the number of reads as a cut-off
rather than the proportion now there's a
caveat here that this is not something
to run with because these samples are
all again the same sample they all have
the same biomass we still haven't
investigated what the impact of if we
have a low biomass sample if there's an
if there's an effect with library size
and and contaminants this is a study
that I want to highlight that actually
has taken started to take a look at the
role of contaminants and low biomass the
the authors of this study took a sample
consisting of a single species
and sort of in Reverse they created new
samples based on repeated serial
dilutions of the poop that sample and so
you can see this is a results out at the
bottom for four different DNA extraction
kids they're really they were
investigating the contamination in the
DNA extraction kits and when does the
contamination overtake the signal in the
original in the original sample and you
can see that as the biomass and
decreases for each of these extraction
kicks we observe more of the of the
contaminants and so this is a this is a
really simple experiment we I feel like
we need we need more experiments like
this to be able to understand what is
the role of contaminants when it's
something present vs vs not present this
the effects may be different for
different species constraints and and
that needs to be investigated as well so
to summarize my recommendations for
addressing our ability to detect
quote-unquote rare tax or determine what
a rare taxon is for our bacteria of
interest for example for hours with
chlamydia and then of course several
others we I advocate for experiments
with mock communities and environmental
samples where we spike it in greater and
greater amounts of that bacteria and
look at the concentration at which we're
able to begin to detect it in our
pipelines based on our experiments with
the positive controls it appears that we
should use the number of reads and not
the proportions to determine the
presence and absence of samples presence
and absence of bacteria for samples with
sufficient biomass also we should
monitor a positive and negative controls
for contaminants of course I'm assuming
we all run positive and negative
controls I think that has become pretty
standard and
microbiome research what has what is not
standard is that we published our
controls results and I think that's
important and we should own beyond just
eyeball using an eyeball test to look at
what are what are contaminants that
we're that our technical variation is
low but also to ensure that we are the
things that we're measuring in our
communities are in fact true signals and
not not contaminants from the land okay
so now I'll move on to a common view
number two and that is that confirming
differences in biological origin can be
used to evaluate analysis methods so we
see this a lot that clustering and
principal coordinates analysis is often
used to confirm or refute refute
findings and here I've got a PCO a plot
that I made with our data the colors
indicate the different body sites and so
we were trying to try to demonstrate
that the samples from different body
sites cluster together now this
clustering a PCO a I claim is for this
is for exploration and discovery and
that we should use more rigorous methods
for confirming our our discoveries and
use statistical hypothesis test for for
making statements about about different
samples so I'm going to say something
that I think is I think everyone can
agree on but is still going to come
across as somewhat controversial and
that is that clustering it inherently
unreduced will and that is because we
all know that when we cluster whether it
that be sequences or samples or whatever
small changes in our data can
dramatically
change the results and this is because
the transitive property there's no
transitive property of distances point
if a sample a as close to sample B
example be as close to sample see it
means nothing about the relationship
about a and C so again this is for
clustering and PCO AI think should just
be used for initial discovery only and
not for confirming our discoveries so we
should go back to like I said more
fundamental methods for for the
statements that we want to make the
reason for this is that we don't know
the true error rate or the the power
that we should have for environmental
samples so for example I see often
statistical methods are evaluated on
their ability to detect the environment
of origin save samples from different
body sites we looked at throat versus
tongue earlier now there are two
different environments we would expect
that the we have the catch to be
slightly different because the
conditions are different different
bacteria will thrive there however there
are certainly samples from the throat
from one subject that might look like
tongue samples from another and we don't
know what that true that true overlap is
so I want to digress a little bit and
talk a little bit about clustering for
clustering of sequences for which you
identification I I also think that I
also see that this can be problematic in
in in in many in drawing conclusions
from 16s surveys what we do when we when
we group our sequences together to if we
if we use it 02 unison you cluster your
sequences at ninety-seven percent
sequence identity to identify species or
strains and then go back and name the
name the clusters well again that's
unreadable but also
these sequences have contained about 3%
two to three to four percent sequencing
error and so we end up with a very large
overestimation it seems of the number of
ode to be used and the number of strains
that are actually in a sample that's
because we are clustering at
ninety-seven percent sequence identity
but we have three percent error so we're
going to end up with a lot of fuzziness
around the edges of our of our clusters
and even if we process the same sample
twice so go and sequence it twice will
likely end up with very different photo
to use so that's that clustering
sequences I started out talking about
clustering samples so when we once we
assign taxonomic bins and we're looking
at groups of samples i mentioned i
mentioned again that that when we're
looking at comparing environment we need
to base an evaluation methods but on on
data where we know the true error rate
which of course is not in environmental
samples so my recommendations so to
understand the power for analysis method
so again this important this this
depends on what questions we want to
answer but if we want to answer the
question is this group of samples
different from this group of samples we
need to use simulations to calculate
powerful for the method power is only we
can only calculate power when we know
the distribution for which the data
arrive with the caveat that the results
of the simulation only as good as the
assumptions okay if we don't have the
right distribution that reflects with
what our environmental samples come from
then then then then the results don't
translate I think to to understand when
differences can be detected I think
again all communities can be useful here
so you can start with mock communities
and spike in
means in different quantities and I
expect it will depend on what your
spiking in but determine at what point
you're able to distinguish different
communities and then back to the ideas
about assigning taxonomy I tend to
advocate for these of an alignment based
method if you have a reference database
which we're beginning to have them
available for reliable databases for 16s
data hopefully down the road we'll have
them for other sequencing-based data of
course speed speed in space is an issue
but alignment based methods were
possible we can use a combination of
composition based methods such as RDP
which is going to classify DNA fragments
based on word fragments in the in the
DNA fragment you see you can classify
down to certain taxonomic level based on
that and then use an alignment based
method to refine it or if if we decide
that you can't refine those those
classifications based on 16s the 16s
gene so if you're interested your
particular environment of interest
you're interested in particular species
and the species have identical 16s gene
then we need to change technology right
need to change to whole genome shotgun
sequencing or some other way of
surveying the environment okay so move
on to common view 3 that is that
processing more environmental samples is
preferred to processing replicates I
think the significance of this is
quarters of course that we need to
understand technical variation so
replicates are are essential to
understanding how much variation how
much signal there is beyond the the
noise and our measurements I think that
technical variation is largely
uncharacterized and in much much of our
sequencing approaches and I have a quote
here from a problem
statistician I heard not so long ago
statisticians job is to characterize
variation in the data so that we can
understand when the signal exceeds
exceeds the noise on this particular
common view I think perhaps it's private
a little bit overstated by
biostatisticians it it's kind of a
carryover from the days of analyzing
microarray data where we saw lots and
lots of batch to batch variation and
there were there were adjustments that
needed to be made to to bring things
into bring their samples or the sample
batches into harmony to be able to
analyze them together with microbiome
data particularly 16s data so far it's
very refreshing that technical variation
appears to be rather low what I have
here on this slide as a result of of
analyzing replicates from 240 mock
communities so so there's 240 samples a
subset of them are replicates of one
another there were three different
experiments and I'll I'll explain I'll
explain more about this experiment later
when we go through common view number
four without bias but in the first
experiment which for the red for the red
boxes here they mixed the not
communities were made up of equal
proportions of cells mixed together in
the green for the greenboxes the
communities were made up of growing the
bacteria and pure culture extracting the
DNA and then mixing equal quantities of
DNA and then in the third the blue boxes
we grew the bacteria and kyra culture
extracted the DNA subjected to DNA the
pcr amplification then mix the PCR
product in equal proportions and what
you're seeing here is the technical
variation
for the foot among the replicates and
what's most close to what we see with it
environmental samples is represented by
the red boxes what we're looking at is
the technical variation for each
bacterium separately so the differences
between what we see in one replicate
versus another and the scale here the
scale here seems to indicate that the
technical variation is less than two and
a half percent in general for these for
these samples so the technical variation
is very low and that's like I said it's
refreshing it kind of keeps me kind of
keeps me going in microbiome data
analysis this is this is another
representation of the positive controls
that I mentioned earlier so this is a
172 replicates of the same mock
community a single mock community and
what you see down below are the are the
compositions in a stack bar plot so each
sample is on the x-axis and then you can
see what's in them on the y-axis and by
an eyeball check the composition remains
pretty stable you can see a couple of
runs in there a couple of little white
drifts but this is what I mean when I
say that the technical variation is
rather low and that's in the composition
of the of the samples and this is
despite the fact that and I now refer to
the top figure the total counts that we
observe in the samples varies rather
widely so despite the fact that we end
up with different numbers of reads for
each sample the composition remains
largely stable now one thing I do want
to point out this last bar here is
actually not from a sample but from it
is what is actually in the mock
community so again the technical
variation is the differences between all
these these first 172 samples the last
bar represents what's actually there and
you can
see that this bacterium that's indicated
by the brown color in the bottom that's
enterococcus faecalis it tends to be
underrepresented in what we observe
compared to what's actually in the
sample and the light blew the fuse Oh
bacterium nucleatum tends to be
under-represented compared to what's
what's actually there and same for
several of the other bacteria so the the
bias the difference between what's
actually there and what we observe seems
to be a bigger problem than the
technical variation this is another view
of variation and compared to bias so
we're looking here at our control
experiments again for just one
particular bacterium we're looking at
the observed counts versus the library
size and what you can see is that
library size increases the there's kind
of a fanning out and that's that is a
technical variation which increases with
library size which is what what we would
expect the black line on this curve now
is actually represents what's actually
in the sample and so the difference in
the slopes of these two lines is the the
bodice so the fanning out of the points
is the variation the difference in the
slopes is the bias and again the bias
seems to be a bigger problem okay so to
harness technical variation
recommendations are to to look at
replicates of both environmental and
positive control samples and measure the
variation we have we have ways of
incorporating estimates of technical
variation into the into our statistical
tests and then keep in mind the bias
appears to be a much bigger problem
which I will which I'll address now
okay so common view for is that the
observed abundances in 16 up there may
be distorted so this bias is not a is
not as no secret but the common view is
that rank abundances are preserved that
if we see more of one bacterium that
another bacterium then it must be
President greater quantities in the
environment and and I claim we don't we
actually don't know the answer to that
of course the significance is that box
can affect the hypotheses and the claims
we make about community composition and
and presley we can make about relative
abundances so we don't know if rank
abundances are preserved we I'm going to
give you partial answers to questions 2
through 4 including how much bias is due
to each processing step whether there's
an interaction well I shouldn't say
interaction whether whether it matters
that particular bacteria are present
together in a sample or is by of an
independent effect on each organism and
also can this be modeled and I'll show
you how we develop models that we apply
to to environmental samples so this is a
another product again I showed this pod
earlier this is the positive controls it
shows that the technical variation tends
to be low but the bias tends to be tends
to be a bigger issue i have another
example well in a minute this is a this
is a reference to the paper we wrote
recently summarizing these results there
was a quite a bit of criticism of our
use of the word metagenomics in the
title which perhaps some of it deserved
it's at least provocative but um I we
can we perhaps we can leave that
discussion for
the cocktail hour of the conference but
I'm going to present results from this
paper if you want to refer to it later
so first this is another example of bias
what we're looking at here is a mock
community for the same not community the
actual composition is all the way on the
right here and what we tested were two
different pcr protocols in terms of
number of cycles 30 and 35 and two DNA
extraction kids and what you can see is
that the number of PCR cycles did not
make a tremendous impact on on what we
observed but the choice of DNA
extraction kit did make a rather large
difference and each of them distorted
the community composition in different
ways and i just want to point out that
despite no matter how how many advances
in sequencing technology we have we will
still have bias because we we have to
extract DNA and DNA extraction is is
going to be an issue as well as as i
presented earlier PTR primer design
so I guess this is again an outline of
the steps of 16s sample processing steps
which we thought to quantify the the
amount of bias from each step we're
looking here at DNA extraction pcr
amplification and then we'll group the
sequencing and taxonomic classification
steps together I guess before we go on I
do want to mention i think bias is why a
likely why we often see i would say
studies or successful studies that are
based only on presence absence of
bacteria because we're not making this
correction for for bias were really our
only true signal is present absence and
that's why you see in use of things like
unweighted unif rec brick breaker
district hard distances that that seem
to seem to recover better signal I also
wanted to mention that you know I showed
the results with the replicates of the
positive control that we need more than
just that sample the positive control to
be able to model what happens to be able
to model what happens with bias and also
to be able to detect interaction I
shouldn't say interaction some
relationships between the signals
whether it's an independent independent
effect or not on unease bacterium ok so
our experiment can we could we we
conducted three experiments in the first
what we did this schematic illustrates
all three of them in the first
experiment what we did was we took a
small set of bacteria we had seven
bacteria of interests speaking of
interests and we mixed equal proportions
of cells equal numbers of cells together
in a sample subjected them to DNA
extraction pcr amplification and
sequencing classify them so we mix them
at different in different mixtures
consisting
two three four and seven bacteria what
you're seeing here the results of mixing
all seven bacteria together what you see
at the bottom down here this is what we
observed and what we went what went in
was equal proportions of each bacterium
in a second experiment we took those
same bacteria we grew them in culture we
extracted the DNA mixed the DNA and
equal proportions of DNA and then
subjected them to PCR amplification and
sequencing and taxonomic classification
and observe the result and by comparing
the results of experiment 1 and 2 we can
isolate the effects of DNA extraction
bias and quantify it in the third
experiment what did was we took the pure
we grew the cells in culture extracted
the DNA and subjected to the pure DNA to
pcr amplification then mixed pcr product
and and then sequence attackman and
classifies and what we see here is that
there's there's not a not a lot of bias
but what by comparing the results of
experiment two and three experiments two
and three we can quantify the effect of
PCR bias on on our measurement and by
comparing the results of experiment
three with our original mixing
proportions we can quantify the bias due
to our bio informatics protocols now
this is with the caveat that we're
working with a small subset of bacteria
our environmental samples tend to be
much richer than this and so not all of
our conclusions can extrapolate to to
the types of environments so this is a
description here the columns here
described as the names of the bacteria
that we use the seven bacteria that we
used these experiments we had 65
different blends and then 15 replicates
and I present a results on the
replicates before so that was 80 total
blends for 80 total mixtures for each
freak experiment so our goal is again to
quantify bias at each step to identify
relationships and then to build models
to predict actual community composition
based on the observed proportions and
just to kind of summarize our results
before I go through them in more detail
we found that contaminating bacteria and
the sequencing error and taxonomic miss
classification contributed little to
bias again this is for small small
amount communities DNA extraction pcr
amplification seemed to be the major
players here we did find that the it
depends on what other bacteria are
present in a sample as to whether the
signal will be amplified or suppressed
and in Australia models that we applied
to the clinical samples shortly so this
is this is a plot of our observed versus
expected counts of gardnerella vaginalis
one of the species across all the
different mixtures for experiment one
where we're mixing equal numbers of
cells and so the the blue line here fits
what we observed and the black line is
what we knew what we know to be no no
should be in the in the samples and so
the the difference between these lines
the difference in the slope the way that
it they fan out from each other
indicates that there's first nurse bias
and the fanning out indicates that the
bias depends on the library size
seems to depend on the library science
now I'll show you the results for this
experiment along with the other two so
the experiment one is now in the top
left the other two after the once we
remove the buyers from DNA extraction
there's no longer a fanning out so it
appears that the bias is independent of
library size once we remove DNA
extraction by who did the DNA extraction
bias and then the after we mix when we
mix equal amounts of pcr product there
appears to be almost no no bias it's
almost gone away so this slide
summarizes the effect of the different
steps on each particular bacterium so
let's start on the on the far left we
have a diploma imagine a and for the DNA
extraction bias which is what this says
is that in general for the experiments
DNA extraction was unfavorable to a dopo
be imagined a which means that we would
tend to observe less than what's
actually there okay in contrast pcr
amplification it seems to be slightly
give a slight boost to the signal in
other words pcr amplification tends to
be slightly favorable to add a probiem
we would tend to see slightly more than
what's actually there sequencing and
classification does not seem to have
much of an effect and so the total which
is kind of a cumulative effect of these
is that in general we're going to tend
to see less out of probiem than what's
actually in the sample we can contrast
this perhaps with say like the bacillus
crispness in the middle here where DNA
extraction tends to actually be
favorable to lack of a soul is Chris
pitous we tend to see more than what's
actually there pcr amplification
suppresses the signal overall there's a
slight bias downwards being we're going
to be slightly left lack of this witless
than what we then what is actually in
the sample
and chlamydia in the eye all the way on
the right all of the each of the steps
tends to be favorable to Smith iya in
the cumulative effect is that we tend to
see more sneakier than what's actually
than what's actually in the sample so
the difference preps have different
effects on on different bacteria this is
kind of zooming in on a particular pair
of bacteria so the actual sample
comprised was comprised of equal amounts
of lactobacillus Chris pitous and Group
B Strep that's a yellow and the orange
in experiment one where we mix equal
amounts of cells we could get in the end
we see about eighty-five percent of the
sample we observe in eighty-five percent
of the example is my chrysalis crisp it
isn't only fifteen percent is Group B
Strep if we remove DNA extraction bias
and experiment 2 it actually turns the
other way we actually tend to see we see
more through B Strep than than lack of
the souls Chris Perez and then in
experiment 3 when removed being an
extraction and pcr amplification bias
almost all devices that has been removed
so here I have a table and perhaps this
is the most important one and yet the
most difficult to explain particularly
to biologists so we're looking at
antagonistic and synergistic
relationships and actually the term in
experimental design is to say
antagonistic and finish its interactions
but I don't want you to think that these
bacteria are actually interacting or
physically interacting with each other
this is this is merely a relationship
among the signal so in other words it in
some sense is that platonic relationship
among the bacteria so up top we have
synergistic relationships and if you
look at the first column we have
lactobacillus precipitous and in the
list below that are the bacteria that we
say are synergistic with lactobacillus
meaning that based on our statistical
models it's lactobacillus is in
an example with these other two other
bacteria we're going to tend to observe
more lactobacillus than what is actually
there and we have them ranked by the by
the effect here in contrast the down
below in the antagonistic table so
underneath say lactobacillus
christopher's we have two bacteria
listed as antagonistic with
lactobacillus when these bacteria are
present would like to bacillus
precipitous we're going to tend to see
less lactobacillus Crispus and what's
actually there and I think you know just
just having this this slide these are a
lot of the major players that we see in
our environmental samples and just being
able to qualitatively if not
quantitatively adjust our observations
of what we get in our data I think it's
valuable so for example this seems to be
when when we have when lactobacillus
iners is pregnant with gardnerella
vaginalis lactobacillus is tend to be
thought time to be more associated with
health should be protective however the
gardnerella we're going to kind of see
more lactobacillus then when its present
with Gardner all gardnerella which is
traditionally thought to be as a sign of
dysbiosis so in other words some of our
profiles might look better than they can
they actually are okay so rakoff I want
to describe an application to clinical
samples so this is stacked bar lots that
represent for clinical samples from the
same subject and what you can see is the
number of days between samples here the
the PA to the measured pH these are
vaginal samples and the the diagnosis at
the visit what what we tend to do with
the with the vaginal samples too often
to simplify our analysis and to capture
major shifts and
at least longitudinally we class intend
to classify samples based on their
predominant bacterium and before i get
into analyzing these further on i'm
going to show you this is kind of a this
is a stack bar plot in a heat map of
about fifteen hundred of hours of our
samples here and you can see that it's
pretty compelling grouping of subjects
based on predominant bacterium and in
this rule predominant bacterium is this
data set independent and and again by
classifying them based on this we can
when we start to look at longitudinal
samples that helps to to try to measure
major shifts in the in the microbiome so
this back to the this sample the first
sample here was the subject was
diagnosed with bv despite the fact that
we would have classified this sample as
being of the lactobacillus iners type is
it was the predominant bacterium even
though there is some gardnerella
vaginalis assign of dysbiosis in the in
the sample and our predicted values over
here on the right what you see though is
that we predict actually that there's
much more gardnerella there than we then
we observe in much left lactobacillus
iners so that seems to match up better
with the with the diagnosis i also want
to talk about this last sample here the
the one has it has a the highest ph
among the samples it has a ph of 5.5
there was no there was no diagnosis say
it was just an annual exam but it was
the highest ph and yet it did not have
the it had a significant amount of
lactobacillus iners observed and and not
as much gardnerella as as as some of the
as any of the other samples well as not
as much garner L observed as the second
sample which had a lower pH however in
the predicted values we observe that the
fourth sample has actually has the most
gardnerella which
aligns better with the fact that the ph
was measured as highest ok so the
recommendations here are to conduct
experiments with not communities with
staggered proportions so staggering
proportions is something we did not do
we use traditional statistical
experimental design which which told us
to use mixing at equal proportions and
we realize afterwards that there are
many questions we still don't know the
answer to and that's the subject of
ongoing work is whether rank abundance
is preserved and so that that's why we
need to use staggered proportions what I
presented to you is all that we've
learned based on mixing with equal
proportions that that's quite a bit but
there's still more two more to go and
use these results to at least
qualitatively hedge our results based on
observations from these mock communities
so to summarize I just want to point out
there I feel there are many unanswered
questions regarding reproducibility and
then their their experiments with not
communities and controls that we need to
do in order to in order to be able to
compare results across different labs
and different environments we talked
about rare taxa assessing detection
using spiked samples avoid clustering
for confirming things use it for
discovery it's a great tool for
discovery but I think it's something we
should use for we should use other
methods for confirming discoveries
assess technical replicate a technical
variation and use that in our in our
test and then finally of course the bias
assess and modeled by us using mock
communities so I want to recognize
members of my other team we have kind of
a vertical integration of a human
microbiome project it could be see you
some clinicians all the way to
bioinformatics asst and analysts at the
other end i also have at the top here
listed several group members i worked
with it sanvi last year biostatisticians
and they helped with many
full discussions with that I'll close
and and take any questions thank you
thank you dr. Brooks for that
interesting presentation I want to
quickly remind our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box found by clicking on green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation we go and dr. Brooks will
answer as many questions as time permits
now we do have one first question in our
cue from gene plant we know that we have
an important bacterial flora in
different organs including the mouth are
the bacteria that we consider useless or
harmful are they important for the
survival of our own flora as if without
these bad bacteria does our bacterial
flora survive I'm not sure I'm qualified
to answer that but but I would point to
the previous presentation Jack Gilbert's
presentation about what is the role of
bad bacteria perhaps these bad bacteria
interacts with our immune system in ways
that we don't know to build up certain
signaling pathways and I think with our
other omics technologies when we get
beyond just what's there and what the
composition is actually what they're
doing and understanding the the messages
that they're having that the cells are
passing to our host cells via
metabolites I think we'll be able to
answer those questions and isolate them
and integrate a resolution thank you dr.
Brooks I don't see any more questions at
this time I'd like to ask you if you
have any final comments on your
presentation um no I the presentation
should be available and I believe my
contact information is available as well
how do you happy to answer any questions
off on thank you dr. Brooks I'd also
like to thank the audience for joining
today and questions that we didn't get
answered today or if you have additional
questions we can definitely take care of
those just webcast can be viewed on
demand through februari 2016 lab roots
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay then we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time thank you
very much goodbye